All right, we almost reached the end of today's course.
What we're gonna talk about now
is how to share your project
once you've got it all ready to go.
So there is a panel called the media panel,
which we will show here as we get into Twinmotion.
So we'll take a look at that,
but just briefly going over it,
you'll see that to export,
all you merely have to do is to click the export icon,
then the image and select the image in the pop-up window.
And next, you'll just get to click the start button
at the very bottom and select the folder
you want to export it to.
It's that simple.
Now there are some other exporting available to you,
but let's take a look here first back into Twinmotion.
And we're gonna go to our little media
right down here, the doc,
and you'll see there's a bunch
of different things available,
which we didn't get into,
but we will in later courses.
But let's just say we wanna export something.
Say I like that, so I'm gonna click that.
Now you'll see we have a simple image.
Now there are other ones that were provided
with this project, but we are not doing that right now.
But now I just wanna export it.
To export, we merely come down here to the export,
click on that.
And over here, you'll see we have quite a few options
of exporting, we can do a presentation, a panorama, a video.
We can even upload it to the cloud
for those that have subscriptions
are able to upload to the cloud.
So for now, we're just gonna talk about the image.
In later courses, we will go through each
and every one of these, but for now,
let's just go ahead and click the image right there.
And I did name it class project.
So go ahead and hit on class project,
and then start your export.
And you should get where you want to select
to export that scene to and wherever you want,
go ahead and place that downloads whatever
if you have a special folder and just hit select folder,
and you'll get the exporting, give you an estimated time.
And once that's done, that's it.
You now have an image to share with someone, friends,
colleagues, clients, whatever,
that will be available to you.
You'll see it gives you an estimated time, how long,
depending on your type of computer that you have.
Now here's a great link that shows other ways
of sharing your projects with Twinmotion,
our documentation online, but that's it.
Now I do hope you've enjoyed this
and let's move on to the final, the wrap up.